hello and thank you for joining us today
my name is dr. Ruth Whittaker director
of the laboratory Quality Assurance and
proficiency program at RTI International
RTI International and its Centre for
forensic sciences helps bridge the gap
between science and law as we support
forensic science laboratories and
practitioners while promoting innovation
and advancement solving the most
challenging issues in forensic science
lab roots is pleased to assemble
academic scientists research scholars
biochemists toxicology and healthcare
professionals and top leaders for both
industry and academia from all over the
world to its inaugural forensics and
toxicology conference forensics and
toxicology 2019 shares a deep insight
into the evolving research and trends
and cutting-edge technology applications
in forensic toxicology pharmaceutical
and environmental toxicology and
forensic science disciplines the agenda
not only aims to deliver a educational
opportunity for attendees but to promote
top-level research thus making the
discussions and presentations focused on
recent outstanding achievements in this
pioneering field this day will be
dedicated to cover a wide spectrum of
themes and will tackle important issues
including human health impacts of
environmental chemical exposures new
concepts in forensic investigation
generating authentic research experience
in forensic based projects in vitro
screening approaches to estimate human a
patek responses to xenobiotic exposures
and what's new in forensic toxicology
and pharmacology as it relates to drugs
and standards composed of five
thought-provoking discussions by
nationally recognized experts the
program kicks off with a keynote
delivery by dr. Linda Birnbaum director
of the National Institute of
Environmental Health Sciences and
board-certified toxicologist addressing
chemical exposures and how they need in
packed
health and identify opportunities to
change our environment and in the
closing keynote dr. Henry Lee one of the
world's foremost forensic scientists
will explain the interaction between
crime scene and forensic science and
different types of evidence and
techniques used in the forensic field
and more this conference will deliberate
and desist and discuss all different
aspects of this topic and provide a
dynamic interactive platform to maximize
learning via live streaming video
webcasts and networking with peers in
the virtual lounge be sure to enter the
exhibit hall and explore showcased
technologies at the booths and engage
real-time with sponsor representatives
for a multi-faceted perspective on the
latest innovations and novel
applications in forensic and laboratory
medicine and medical technology on
behalf of the invited presenters and
sponsors lab roots is proud to bring you
this online symposium and collaborative
informative experience we're looking
forward to enlightening sessions from
distinguished speakers sharing new and
exciting insights in facilitating
scientific advancements and future
collaborations in forensics and
toxicology thank you for your
participation and enjoy